Let’s welcome Martellus to the Gridiron Heights writer's room
We’re so excited to have him executive producing and writing and directing Episode 303
Just being retired, I thought it would be really funny to check into a retirement home
with guys who are already retired
You should have Ray Lewis, like
“When I moved into the retirement home, crime dropped 100 percent”
And then I could be like
"Help!"
And then you could see Cutty, like, walking by in the background
Yeah
You see him the first time, Cutty! Help!
And he just, like, peeks back in
And he’s like
"Cigarette?"
I’m doing all my lines first
You’re retired. It’s not safe for you to be on your own.
I survived a 28-3 deficit
That’s so f--cked up
Yeah
Cutty! I need heeeelp!
Cigarette?
There we go miscommunicating again
My in season record is 2,500, and I think I can beat that now
That’s just ridiculous
"Get Out" was a great movie
Retired athletes have no life
Yeah, it’s a full Marty episode